Moscow said it captured the Eastern
Ukrainian town of salidar which would be
its first major gain since July
Kiev says the fighting around the town
continues but Russian State media is
already celebrating
the reports have Amplified this
as Russia's recent advances there offer
President Vladimir Putin a rare
opportunity to celebrate it's allowed
him to claim a victory after a series of
very humiliating losses
but the reality on the ground is more
complicated than propaganda reports
suggest highlighting the questions about
what's next in the war
solidar a town with a pre-war population
of 10 000 people has been the focal
point of Russia's offensive and media
coverage in recent weeks
it is just a few miles north of the
larger city of bakmud which Russia has
unsuccessfully tried to seize for months
now
Russian media has described both solidar
and back mode as critical for Ukraine is
but Western officials and Military
analysts are skeptical about solidar's
importance get what's been happening
over the last 10 and a half months
particularly in the Dom boss towns and
Villages have swapped hands quite
frequently
and Beyond solidar even if fahmoud fails
defense experts say the cost of six
months of fighting in the area far
outweighs any operational Advantage from
Moscow it has been the most brutal
theater in the war over the last six
months and Western intelligence
estimates that each side in the conflict
is now had about a hundred thousand
casualties recent satellite images also
show numerous bomb creatives from
artillery Oliver buckmut suggesting
Russia has spent High volumes of
ammunition in the offensive
the price Russia pays for the contested
territory is missing from the state
media coverage while reports highlight
the heavy losses suffered by Ukraine
we don't have exact estimates for
Ukrainian losses but Ukrainian officials
have repeatedly said that the fighting
is is very difficult and there have been
heavy losses on both sides now even if
the state propaganda is enthusiastic
about the prospects of Russia's campaign
Ukraine says the celebration is
premature as fighting continues
the big question is if Ukraine can
regroup and establish a second line of
defense and stop Russian advances where
they are or if Russians will continue to
break through and if it's the first
scenario then this will not be a very
significant loss for ukrainians
um and if it's the second it could have
a larger impact